you
you
you
hey there you're watching GameSpot daily
the new show where we cover the top
stories in 30 to 15 minutes or less
we've been doing less lately
excuse the weird count on the beginning
if you're watching live we have some
cash attack blame Tay yeah we have some
technical difficulties which of course
we always blame Tay for I'm Callie and
today I'm joined by Jake hello how's it
going sorry
it's good Michaels out he's at an event
and that means that you're stuck with us
today for the news which is fine it's
exciting it is I'm excited I don't know
if a lot of people are excited about it
though okay well we can see let us know
in the comments if you're excited and be
nice all right first up we got no man's
sky multiplayer details and release
dates the no man's sky next update
that's what it's called the next update
is free for ps4 Xbox one and PC versions
of the game starting July 24th that's
the same day no man's sky launches on
Xbox one and we knew that date already
but we learned more about so yes not
free for Xbox one Oh
update is free the game is not free for
Xbox one but yeah alright take it away
you know lots about no man's guy
well they've been talking about this for
a while now I think they announced the
next a couple months ago but people have
been wanting multiplayer since the game
launched and they kind of said there was
multiplayer and then they kind of said
there was a multiplayer and then an
update they added these little orbs that
you could find and those are supposedly
other people but this is finally the
fully fledged at least that's what it
seems like the fully fledged multiplayer
that people have been waiting for it
looks like they've also added third
person mode but it looks really cool I
mean you can apparently there's
unlimited building options you can
explore with friends you can destroy
freighters with friends loot with
friends do all sorts of fun exploring
with friends so if you could do stuff
with your friends essentially also
random players online um we do have a
quote from Hello games with two actually
the first is that you can help friends
to stay alive or prey on others to
survive I feel like the rhyming is
unintentional and then the second one is
you can build tiny shelters or complex
colony
that are shared for all players but as a
pirate or a wingman in epic space
battles with friends and enemies race
EXO craft across weird alien terrain
creating race tracks and trails to share
online the character customization
allows you to personalize your
appearance cool so also something they
added that I think is really cool that I
don't know if a lot of people think the
same but they've added certain planets
have rings now which they didn't have
before which always felt strange right
like I'm exploring all these solar
systems but why are there no rings but
now planets have rings and it looks
really cool back in the tray little bit
we'd see we saw them approaching a
planet with a giant ring around it
[Music]
literally this phone you're talking
about no back a little bit right there
there we go look at that that looks
pretty cool so space you're talking did
you talk any bit of any bit I don't know
what I'm saying it's too early for this
there's a visual makeover to the game
that was also introduced in this update
and they're talking about the Rings
that's not specifically what you were
referring to there's dramatic well this
is actually from hello games quote
dramatically improved planetary terrain
generation ground textures water and
clouds also significantly more detail
added to ships NPCs and buildings you
talked about the planetary rings there's
improved space visuals and oh and like
you said the new option to play in third
person which we saw a little bit yeah
it's I imagine a lot of this is because
it's coming to Xbox one with X
enhancements so it kind of I don't know
I mean it seems like a good opportunity
to buff up the engine add more detail
which I thought the game was pretty as
is but still there definitely some some
aspects where I was like I wish there
was little more detail in this I wish
the draw distance is a little better
which I don't know if the draw business
will improve but yeah I don't know I
think a nice little makeover is good for
it yeah and he talked about commanding
freighters a little bit you could
upgrade a group of frigates using a
freighter as a mobile command center you
can send your frigates out to explore on
their own or travel with you and you can
invite your friends aboard to play
together a lot of lot of emphasis on the
friends
yeah yeah I think that's the big thing
well it's a lonely galaxy Oh lonely
universe um so you you seem excited for
you gonna be playing it when it comes
out on July 24th I will be playing it
awesome all right there you have it no
man's sky I feel bad for no man's sky
after everything that happened to it and
I'm glad to see hello games still
supporting their game and not just going
into the shadows
two years later mm-hmm all right next up
we got more updates coming to games this
is a little more complicated to me
because my brain has trouble following
along with this so just bear with me the
Final Fantasy 14
slash Monster Hunter World crossover now
has dates for both games the thing I get
confused about is which game we're
talking about when we're talking about
the crossovers because you'll get
Monster Hunter World stuff in Final
Fantasy 14 and Final Fantasy stuff in
Monster Hunter world it's both it's it's
both ways now I thought it was just
Final Fantasy 13 coming to Monster
Hunter yes we have learned so we already
knew that monster in her world would see
Final Fantasy Final Fantasies behemoth
and Dragoon inspired armor that's coming
on August 1st but we just learned that
Final Fantasy 14 is getting its half of
the crossover on August 7th the rathalos
aka the king of the skies and Monster
Hunter will be available for players to
fight in two different trials the normal
version will let you team up with
another seven players to fight the
Rathalos and the extreme version
restricts you to a team of four which
makes it the very first four player
trial in Final Fantasy 14 so that's
pretty pretty intense sounding I don't
know a whole lot about Final Fantasy 14
but I had a lot of friends who play it
and a lot of friends who also play
Monster Hunter so it works out be that
crossover makes sense there's a lot of
big swords big monsters stuff like that
the trial requirements you must be level
70 you must have completed the main
storm blood quest line I think I
actually okay
I timed that okay and there's special
rewards that you can earn by completing
the Rathalos battle
rathalos mount Rathalos armor set palico
and pookie minions in a barbecue fire
spit burnishing I like the barbecue fire
spit I like Palika the face that one
just made was pretty great it's pretty
good
I'm I would is there like a palico
spin-off game where I could just like
raise little palak O's because I would
play that I don't know forgive me if if
there is and I don't know about it but I
would like to know about it now raise
palak O's that like go on little
adventures for you bring back stuff yeah
and I just have a little village of
pelicans yeah it's like Nick OS to me
but with a monster hunter twist yeah a
PSA for you guys monster hunter world is
coming to PC on August 9th we of course
knew that but if you forgot I did forget
you forgot the monster hunter world is
coming to PC it is and the the Final
Fantasy 14 content that is coming two
months from our world this is the part
that's hard for me is coming August 7th
so if you can wait two days and you want
to play on PC because maybe you play I
don't know maybe you like games on PC
then you can wait a couple days for that
alright so there's that
woo we're almost there guys one more
real story and then a couple shut up
alright okay oh wait I have to I'm doing
both things today normally Michael does
the the buttons the switching and I do
this stuff over here I offered to help
but she said no I don't know okay final
Halle Knight DLC gets a release date
plus some cool merch holo nights gods
and glory DLC comes to switch and PC on
August 23rd it's the fourth and final
DLC pack for the game it's 100% free
there's new bosses NBC's quests and
music so that is coming I was gonna say
very soon that's not very soon but in a
month mm-hmm it's it's launching so
that's pretty cool I know we got a
couple hollow Knight fans in the office
well Mary Kisch is a big Hollow Knight
fan yeah and it was Mike Mike McCarty is
a big Hollow Knight fobs been playing
I've been playing a little bit of it I
haven't got haven't had a chance to play
as much as I like
I played it when it originally came to
PC and I didn't get super far into it
and then I got it on switch when it came
out recently and I've played a little
bit more and it is a very good game not
a lot of direction though you kind of
have to like make your own path which
you might like you might not like but I
think the art style is charming enough
as is in like the bosses are pretty
tough and fun like that guy looks cool
with the paintbrush I'm into it yeah I
like the art style a lot yeah it just
came to switch semi recently so it's
cool that switch is getting the DLC at
the same time which hasn't always been
the case
oh yeah like stardew valley we're still
waiting on that multiplayer update for
switch players and I'm very impatient
about that it's it's still on beta on PC
too it's not like sorry oh yeah but I
was like I kinda just want to wait for
the full thing I think you talk about
the whole game I was like no that's not
true I'm very aware that the game I
don't know is true that's true I'm not
the farming type so thinking of games I
don't know where I was going with that
well sturdy valley has to phone fangamer
and that's kind of the segue I'm going
with because hollow knight also has
stuff out fangamer now the devs partner
with finger for a giant plushie of the
little dude fantasy it's really cute I I
can't bring it up here very easily but
if you go on fangamer i fangamer has
lots I get undertale stuff from a fan
here sometimes all right I mean I don't
regularly buy undertale things but I've
gotten undertale things from fing gamers
so just go to fan gamer and you can see
the little plushie it's very cute and
then finally I did want to shout out
that there's a new Call of Duty Black
Ops for zombies trailer it's really
campy I don't have much to say about it
pretty short isn't it it's like two and
a half minutes but it shows the there's
you know three Maps coming day one it
shows two of those maps one is voyage of
despair I guess I can bring that up and
the other is its 9 button Roman numerals
so it's IX it shows those two maps and
how they're linked with
I think is the the one thing that we
didn't necessarily know but yeah I don't
know it has zombies in it as you might
expect it shows this girl she says some
cheesy lines she talks about right
talked about her dad I do want to say
that the sound design in zombies this is
very good and I I think that's secretly
the best thing about it so yeah I used
to love the zombie modes and I still
kind of do like they're fun from time to
time but yeah it's all I got
well there you have it guys very tepid
just very tepid news day I yeah I don't
really have anything to add not that oh
yeah sorry
cut that behind-the-scenes yeah Michael
will be gone tomorrow
too if you're a big Michael I'm a big
Michael fan but he will be back he's not
dead
so that's good I like that he's not dead
and that's about all we have time for
yeah hopefully there's more new stories
- oh yeah you know sometimes you know
with with Amazon Prime day going on I
think most of our attention here or most
of the news attention was on Amazon
Prime day so including the strike and
boycott which I wrote about so did you
get anything I did not because I was the
strike him supporting I was supporting
the boycott so yeah that was probably
why some of this news is not as exciting
as normal but don't you worry we get
excited to hear about other stuff yeah
I'm excited about no man's sky you are
that was exciting that I'm I'm very
happy for you
I did not play it so that was the time I
guess so right that's about it for us
thank you so much for watching thank you
to Eric a for helping with the
last-minute technical difficulties we
say blame Tay but really we mean thank
you too for all that you do thank you to
Matt Padgett and Tony Wilson for the
notes Thank You Jake
for subbing in today
and thank you for watching we will see
tomorrow have a lovely day